[موسيقى]
نظمت المسيره للمره الاولى عام
1968 على يد الحاخام يهود حساني من
المدرسه الدينيه المعروفه باسم مركاز هراب
وتحولت الى تقليد سنوي تنظم فيما تسميه
سلطات الاحتلال يوم القدس والذي تحيي فيه
ذكر احتلال الشطر الشرقي من المدينه وفق
التقويم العبري عام 67
يمول المسيره جمعيه عن كريبه الدينيه
الاستيطانيه وبلديه القدس ووزاره التربيه
والتعليم الاسرائيليه وشركه تطوير واعاده
تاهيل الحي اليهودي وفي يوم المسيره تجبر
قوات الاحتلال الفلسطينيين على اغلاق
محالهم التجاريه بالتزامن مع مرور المسيره
من البلده القديمه حيث يعتدي المشاركون
فيها على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين ويهتفون
الموت للعرب رافعين الاعلام الاسرائيليه
عام 2021 حمل تطورا مهما تحت تهديد
المقاومه الفلسطينيه منعت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو مرور
المسيره عبر باب العامود باتجاه حائط
البراق وساحه البراق وحولت المسار الى باب
الخليل باتجاه حائط وساحه البراق لتفادي
مرورها فيما يسمى الحي الاسلامي
تزامن موعد المسيره انذاك مع شهر رمضان
وبعد تكرار اقتحام المستوطنين للمسجد
الاقصى المبارك اطلقت المقاومه الفلسطينيه
دفعه من الصواريخ باتجاه القدس المحتله
فاجبرت اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه على تفريق
المسيره لتندلع عمليه سيف القدس بعد
انتهاء عمليه سيف القدس نظمت المسيره ضمن
مسارها التقليدي في الخامس عشر من حزيران
يونيو واعتبر ذلك اول قرار مهم للحكومه
الجديده في اسرائيل برئاسه نفتالي بنات
ليمر المستوطنون من باب العامود باتجاه
ساحه البراق واحتفظت مسيره الاعلام
بالمسار عينه العام الماضي قدر عدد
المشاركين فيها بنحو 70 الفا وحشدت لها
قوات الاحتلال نحو ثلاثه الاف عنصر
لتامينها واستدعت ثلاث كتائب تابعه لحرس
الحدود من صفوف الاحتياط عام 2022 والساعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي من دائره نشر منظومه
القبه الحديديه حول القدس وفي مناطق عده
في وسط وجنوب اسرائيل تحسبا لاطلاق
المقاومه الفلسطينيه صواريخ في توقيت
تنظيم المسيره
[موسيقى]